I'm not going to use any salt guess what
we use the most amazing Seeley's you
know I love scrambled egg and so
throughout this series what we have done
it's done the most amazing scumbling
and look we're gonna do now a beautiful
Pow Wow let's come with a beautiful bow
hand dives first me now
from there take out the shower thumb
sign underneath and then literally
literally pounding it like that
tenderizes it so slicing it super thin
it's important cause I want to get it a
nice bit of color and more importantly
this has to be one of the most delicious
sort of abalone sought-after
and get having the seasoning ready first
then do a touch of lime 54 comes out and
it was so tight super quick the amazing
stove oil in get that super hot and it's
waiting need to be really quick and I
mean super quick now power that you've
got my youth of town ideal
the scrambled eggs ever
exempt
now could become a leg stroke I'm not
gonna use any salt guess what we use the
most amazing and then from there
seasoned seaweed he's gonna absolutely
give that
now I go in just give it a mix up super
hot like I said
clean up and down and from there make
sure that butter absolutely
and now to already I can smell out
beautiful see weakness now
[Music]
a cream just a touch back into those
beautiful shells now I've made a lot of
scrambled egg in my time this has been
one of those glamorous 35 million of you
boys get it powwow
scum on eggs right to shine so season
little bit of seaweed chop the power up
so did very quickly and then literally
finished it's amazing how take that
power let me know in the comments what
you think of that amazing scrambled egg
dish and if you missed Uncharted trust
me you can watch it on the link below or
on the Nat Geo app